it's so inspired by only Renaissance art
in Florence I thought I'd take a drawing
class at the academia they oughta pee at
Valley on them oh there we go yeah
that's the nude man yeah up along yes
he's wearing flip-flops but when I think
of great drawings I don't think of a man
wearing flip-flops when I look at great
statues say of Apollo soon I don't see
flip-flops I draw the oval of the head
how's that look okay that's okay yeah a
lot of chest hair and here I see it's
time to address I've not addressed
I've not addressed his genitalia is his
penis of course there's the shaft I was
here at NAC and testicle or testes here
I've drawn it too big they're doing that
favor frankly I'm giving him about a 20%
markup later and then there's this hair
here I mean what we call a narcissist in
America you don't have narcissist is
always end up drawing myself bigger
because it's me
here penis chuckles I usually wear a
suit when I'm on television so I think
I'm gonna put myself I'm gonna bus ya
boss looking in say wait to board the
bus Sam you mind if I bring in a model
with less hair sure this is Jordan I
think a pose would be appropriate
hitchhiking
if you're hitching a ride on your naked
this is called naked man looking for a
ride give me one of these that's good
this is called mentally ill man attempt
miss no laughing please we can't have
laughing you see here the deadness in
the eyes there's no soul
the man has no soul there's just nothing
in there and then legs sort of like a
frog but a frog that's very sickly bad
like oh excuse me because you told me to
best use me excuse me
models speak there's one last pose if
you could face that way and then you
look back with the jaunty look as if to
say check out my butt who gives a thumbs
up
along I want to thank you
Jordan I've sold your clothes don't you
did a nice job
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you